hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm going
to be watching this video called Marvel
vs. DC epic trailer I'm not sure what
this is and just a lot of people have
been saying I should watch it so let's
get to it
the multiverse theory of quantum physics
posits the existence of parallel
universes an infinite number of
ever-growing alternate realities it says
concurrently with our own the theory
holds that anything that can darken will
know this reality
dimensional barrier ruptured unleashing
unknown energies into our world
antimatter dark energy thank you
first
let them fight
it is Sony
Wow
literally the the hair on my head is
filled with chills everywhere on my body
dude that was nuts I hope that means
probably never gonna happen but that
would be [ __ ] sweet if they managed
to put something like that together one
day DC and Marvel were like let's
combine our worlds like that would be
[ __ ] sweet that was awesome it's like
a [ __ ] fantasy come true for anyone
who's ever thought of like what if the
DC Marvel Universe worst each other
what a brilliant [ __ ] video it was
edited perfectly I don't know where all
that footage comes from I mean I
recognize like 90% of it there's a few
things here in there that I'm not that
familiar with still the whole time I was
like blown away it looked real I was
believing everything that was happening
it didn't look like oh yeah they tried
cutting something together but you know
the cuts are obvious the way they come
the user effects to make it look like
certain DC characters were actually in
front of Marvel characters and when they
put DC characters together and other
Marvel characters together haven't been
on the same screen I don't know some of
this was shot just for this no matter
what that is one of the most impressive
fan made videos I have ever seen hands
down holy [ __ ] this better become
something soon or else I will jizz on
the corpse of Hitler don't know why I
went there yeah thank you guys so much
for telling me that was out that was
[ __ ] awesome I'm gonna watch that
again and again and again
I'm going to show this to all my friends
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and yeah
just oh yeah girl is some [ __ ]
awesome oh man if that doesn't make you
want to start watching comic book movies
I don't know what will there should be a
comic book about me [ __ ] on Hitler's
dead but yeah and starting to have
shoutouts again soon just trying to
build it up so go to facebook.com slash
the real reject shoutouts say something
interesting and then wait for your
shout-out at one of the end of these
videos yeah I loved every moment of that
video Wow Wow I can now die